the Prime Minister should be going to  cop he needs to show leadership this is  a hugely important issue climate change  is wound together with the energy crisis  and I think many people would be  expecting the prime minister of the UK  not just to attend cop but to use it as  an opportunity to pull world leaders  together to deal with climate and to  deal with energy and if that doesn't  it's a failure of leadership if I was  prime minister I would be going I would  be convening of pulling people together  and sorting out the issues that are  confronting people talking to people  this morning who can't pay their energy  bills they expect their prime minister  to be on the world stage sorting these  problems out it's an absolute failure of  leadership